Okay.
So I have something really interesting for
us to take a look at today.
I already told you earlier, one of the most
important polls historically in primary elections
is the de Moines register poll of Iowa voters.
Shortly before the Iowa caucus, that poll
came out a few days ago.
It is shortly before the Iowa caucuses.
We already analyzed the poll itself.
Bernie Sanders is leading by several points.
I already told you this is important.
Iowa is not the be all end all the polling
could change between now and the day that,
uh, Iowans go to the caucuses.
But, uh, the, there is no question whatsoever
that winning the Iowa caucus would be a huge
boost of momentum for whoever wins it.
And this is a really big deal for Bernie Sanders,
particularly since he's a candidate that was
blacked out by corporate media for a long
time, ignored, uh, made a foregone conclusion
that he simply cannot win.
And corporate media is in disarray over how
to cover Bernie's surge.
And Bernie's lead in Iowa and they are doing
trap.
He's artistry to get around and underneath
and over.
The reality that Bernie is just doing well
and he may win the Iowa caucus and then he
will be in contention for the democratic nomination.
Doesn't mean South Carolina is going to go
his way.
I know it's popular right away to point out
why Iowa is so white.
As soon as it gets to South Carolina, Bernie
screwed maybe.
Okay, but we're talking about Iowa right now.
I have examples for you from MSNBC and from
CNN.
Let's start with the democratic centrist establishment
channel.
MSNBC, which said headline, Iowa poll questioned
by expert.
That's the headline, not Bernie surges to
lead an Iowa poll.
It's Iowa poll question by expert.
Here's the video associated with that story.
Joanne Reed interviewing Jimmy Williams to
say, can we trust this poll?
Yeah, I guess we can, but the poll can still
change doing everything possible to essentially
say, let's just not really believe that Bernie
is truly in the lead in Iowa.
Take a look.
I am perplexed by this poll for two reasons.
First, either the people of Iowa or schizophrenia
or they just aren't convinced.
They remain skeptical and I don't think the
people of Iowa or schizophrenia, although
they do have two horrifying GOP senators as
their senators, but that's a separate conversation
for a separate day.
This poll is not an outlier.
This is in fact, as I said, the gold standard.
This is it.
When it came out last night at seven o'clock
or whatever time it came out, Eastern time,
I looked at it went, no way in hell is this
right?
But it has to be right because it's Demoine
right the morning register and see it in and
so I mean, I just don't see this.
I think a lot can change between now and the
day of caucuses and I
don't these numbers, they tell me something
at 30,000 feet.
They tell me nothing on the ground in Demoine
or Dubuque or anywhere else.
That's my takeaway from it.
So he knows.
He can't really say it's not accurate because
this is a known very solid pole.
So it's more, well, okay, maybe, maybe we
can't say it's not accurate, but this can
change and we're three weeks out and whatever.
Then income.
CNN, remember this is a Des Moines register,
CNN joint poll.
CNN is onscreen graphic chooses to say now
that Bernie is winning, the headline is no
clear leader.
It's so predictable.
Of course the results Bernie 20 Warren 17
booed edge edge 16 and Biden 15 the headline,
no clear leader and you know it's, it's technically
sort of true.
The margin of error is 3.7 Bernie is up by
three but when it was Biden up by three, the
headlines weren't no clear leader.
The headlines were Biden's winning in Iowa
when it was booted.
Judge, that took a lead in Iowa.
The headlines were not no clear leader.
It was booted judge surges from behind to
take a elite in Iowa.
So this is not, you know, an unhinged, Bernie's
obviously going to a win and everyone's wrong
and it's a conspiracy.
This is yet again the different way in which
corporate media will frame a poll depending
on whether an establishment candidate is winning
or a progressive candidate is winning.
The margin of error in polls in Iowa has been
between three and four for months.
That's not new.
So why is the margin of error now relevant
for saying the headline is no clear winner
when when it was a different candidate, the
margin of error did not play into the headlines
that were chosen by corporate media.
And again, I already gave these disclaimers
earlier.
Winning Iowa is not the be all end all.
You need voters that are very different from
Iowa voters to win the democratic nomination.
Bernie may not have them or he might.
Iowa is not going to tell us that it is a
close poll, but if you look at the trend line
of Iowa polling, you see that Bernie Sanders
bottomed out in Iowa in mid to late September
and he's been up up, up since then.
While Biden is down, Buddha judge popped up,
but now is back down.
Warren is down from where she was and now
the headline that Bernie is winning is no
clear leader when it was always Biden ahead,
booted, judge ahead, Warren surging.
So let's wait and see.
This is one primary at a time, but the lesson
is don't accept corporate media's characterization
of a poll.
Just look at the poll yourself.
Look at the trend lines yourself.
Look at the polling data and the methodology
yourself and be comfortable coming up with
the analysis yourself.
There's too much riding on this and it's too
important to be led by these incorrect narratives
and summaries of polls that someone is choosing
to do.
Do the work to check it out for yourself and
we will all be far better off.
And that gets us now to Trump realizing he
may, he may have to face Bernie Sanders in
the general election.